so you're from second city correct aha
yes and we you is there like a Friday
Saturday company there or no I was on
the e.t.c stage so I performed Thursday
night through Sunday night oh so that's
the main well then there's the main
stage I what I didn't make it that high
I made it to the e.t.c why because it's
just as high it's I no no no why didn't
you go to the top I I was pretty much at
the top okay
Hey hey Gilbert can well we work
together yeah well we will because we do
corporate training videos Second City
has this whole other wing of like
[ __ ] business stuff that you can do
to make money and that's what we've done
yeah so depressing yeah Big Tobacco
training videos training Oh
crushing they write them funny and we
just say the lines but it's so good
improvised one I want to see what will
be like okay so I want sexual harassment
no I like I like I like the tobacco one
okay but you still have to teach them
about sexual harassment in the workplace
oh so it's all [ __ ] morons who work
for Philip Morris all right so watch did
you wanna are you an hour an office in
oh in an office yeah so I'm gonna walk
up you're by the cooler okay okay hey
Tom hey what's going on Jeff do you sell
some menthols today oh I did I would did
two boxes exhale two boxes hey but you
didn't post about it on social media did
you because we wouldn't want anybody on
Facebook to know our inside practices
that is true and you have a really nice
ass hey thanks Jeff I'll see you at the
meeting yes
thanks Jeff that's the sexual what it is
and then they say don't do that yeah
let's do another one
it's soul crush okay you guys do one all
right
hey say my [ __ ] hey are you Joe yeah
hey what's up akita and that would be
the end of the video you can't say you
know call a man a black woman's name you
can't you can't do that alright what
your fitness is see Nikita finish the
same that's a kind of dog joven what you
doing tonight oh you know I'm gonna hit
up the local tavern over across the
street from Fillmore
got a date I do yeah but I'm not gonna
post about it on social media
he's naked from work forward that's how
you do it tell me what the payoffs uh I
mean like a thousand bucks a day
so for me I'm not a big star like me
that's a pretty good yeah it's not bad I
mean I get a commercial a month ago how
much did you make Bobby yeah but I did
but I didn't do commercial - so I'm
gonna say mo struggle the struggle is
real I'm not a household name I'm not a
household name [ __ ] and how you keep
saying yeah I'm gonna play right now
not no house knows my name come on no I
get a aren't you in something I go
whatever you know me time will come
[Music]